We've built a table tennis battleship
arena
First one to pop all five balloons wins
Let's go!
And if you're new the channel
remember to subscribe
To help our channel reach two million
Okay
That's set
There
What's Otto your strategy placing the balloons?
Trying to not get them to pop
Let the battle start!
I'm really nervous
Okay first throw
Otto
Get ready for some explosions!
Not for that
This is so scary
I heard that!
Oh no!
Okay continue Otto
You're on a streak
Yeah
He got it!
Two in a row
That's so lucky Otto!
Get ready for the third one
I think it's somewhere....
There!
I feel like it was quite close
Yes!
Nice shot
Keep it coming Miikka!
I'll also give you two in a row
just to make it fair
Yeah
Not with that you're not
Not even close Otto!
I know
Neither was that
Ah I almost heard the pop
That hit the edge of the table
Nice
Jackpot!
It's 2-2 now
I had a feeling that he'd put it short
I'll go for another short one
There!
Does that count?
Well I think it it counts yeah
Three in a row
Yeah, continue
Okay, 3-2
Miikka is leading
No!
Not anymore!
That's 3-3
There's still two left
Where might they be?
Where might they be.
That was my small one!
Where might the last one be?
I think it's a short one
Or maybe it's in the corner
I'll try the corner once more
Okay
I think I'll go for Otto's
this square
No
Yeah
Noo!
Thank you!
I need to see where you put your balloons
No! I was aiming for this one
The one was quite close
It bounced like here
Okay so this was a fun concept
If you liked this
next time it will be Otto against Emil
Don't forget to hit subscribe
And watch our previous episodes there
Untill next time!